in the corner Gerald bringing water  moving screen on PJ Tucker PJ is mad at  the official Brian Forte oh and then  Tony brothers just tosses PJ Tucker  why does Tony brothers tossing well he's  watching this mannerisms you see Keith  Jones right there's Holden PJ back so  that doesn't get even worse but PJ is  upset and has good reason James Harden  tried to stop him  PJ you know that was a bad call first of  all now here's PJ right here and he's  going in to set a screen and göran  dragon pulls the back of PJ's head yeah  and they call the foul on PJ that's why  he's never set that's a terrible call  and so he goes deprived for days said  hey he pulled me and then he gets tossed  for that